[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur verließ welt ich
werde heute alkoholfreier locker machen
viele von euch haben sich schon torten
gewünschte halliburton und ich habe die
bisher eigentlich nie gemacht denn es
gibt einfach viele die auch keinen
alkohol trinken und deswegen die torte
nicht nachmachen können also gibt es
heute ein basic rezept für alkoholfreien
eilige dann habt ihr die flasche da
könnte aus torten machen das ganze über
eis gießen also richtig richtig lecker
ich zeige euch mal die zutaten für den
alkoholfreien eierlikör verwende ich 75
gramm weiße schokolade 200 milliliter
milch etwas mannil extrakt 6 1 gelbe
etwa 50 gramm puderzucker und 200
milliliter sahne zuerst gebt ihr jetzt
die milch in einem topf so lässt sich
kurz aufkochen und in der zwischenzeit
kann ich hier schon mal wasser kochen
lassen
ich zeige euch heute die methode hier
auf dem herd wer eine küchenmaschine
besitzt mit hitze funktion kann es
natürlich in der küchenmaschine machen
alle zutaten rein
die schokolade schmelzen und dann bei 70
grad etwa 15 minuten erhitzen
also jetzt bin ich kurz aufbauen lassen
hier wasser aufkochen lassen und dann
geht's weiter
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die mönche sitzt aufgekocht jetzt hab
ich dem herd ausgemacht da kommt die
schokolade rein und darf darin schmelzen
die schokolade ist geschmolzen jetzt
kann ich in dieser schüssel alles
berühren also sahne rhein sind natürlich
ganz wichtig weil der lippe wird
und da will man ja auch den typischen
geschmack von den eignern
[Musik]
ein extrakt gibt noch mal ein schönes
aroma jetzt kurz verrührt jetzt die sich
hier die warme stimmung nicht ein
so habe ich dann auch keine gefahr dass
das eigelb gerinnt weil ja schon die
kalte sahne dabei ist sind dann alles
gut verrührt ist muss jetzt die masse
erwärmt werden über dem heißen wasserbad
da müsst ihr jetzt aufpassen dass ai
darf natürlich nicht kochen daher auch
in der küchenmaschine nur bis 70 grad
und ständig rühren
es kommt jetzt hier drauf so dass sich
das wasser ganz leicht nur köcheln unten
drunter und kann es hier für etwas fünf
bis zehn minuten szenisch und dadurch
wird das ei pasteurisiert und die keime
werden abgetötet
[Musik]
nach zehn minuten rühren über dem
kochenden wasser bat ist die marseille
es richtig schön cremig und wenn ihr den
eilig mit alkohol machen wollt nehmt ihr
einfach statt der milch etwas korn und
könnt den so auch haltbarer machen weil
so ist es nur einer woche haltbar und
mit alkohol natürlich ein bisschen
länger den fühle ich jetzt noch ganz
heiß in sauberer ausgewaschene flasche
und hoffe dass ich nicht leckere zu spät
gestoppt und während ich hier die
restliche masse noch um fülle zeige ich
euch jetzt noch einen schoko variante
nämlich schoko eierlikör mit chili dann
nehme ich statt vanille einfach
chiliflocken und bereitet das ganze
jetzt in der küchenmaschine zu ihr habt
ihr dafür auch die anleitung dafür lasse
ich die milch bei höchster stufe kurz
aufkochen und schaltet dann die
temperatur wieder runter jetzt nämlich
statt weißer schokolade einfach dunkel
herren schokolade und lass mir kurz
schmelzen
bezüglich noch die restlichen zutaten
dazu also die sahne die chiliflocken den
puderzucker und zum schluss die eigelbe
über die maße durch stelle die hitze
dann auf 70 grad hoch und rühre den
eierlikör dann für etwa zehn minuten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das ist im hochland schenke man noch
etwas ein ja wir kommen und auf dem rad
noch mal probieren so schlüssel mal
wieder nicht weil ja alles okay auf dem
bau ich habe mein geld macht ohne
alkohol einmal vanille einmal schoko
chili alkoholfrei wie geht es mit weißer
schokolade sahne und er hat es probiert
wo das war ich musste mich in schutz
nehmen es war indisches chili wo was ich
strahle ich hab nur noch in banken dann
trinke ich das trikot tauschte man schon
mal getroffen
mir schmeckt es mir schon ein gewissen
drängt oder was machen
da schmeckt lecker lecker schmeckt
lecker und ich bin richtig gut dann ist
es war für mich für echte männer
ja und das für dich ich pack's gerne
rosa s ich habe das auch vegan machen
naja ich weiß auch wie man einfach um
die flasche kommt drauf schreiben macht
[Musik]